[Applaudissements]
ils étaient une dizaine ce matin devant
les locaux du chaînon à montréal pour
encourager caroline paradis cette mère
de famille s'est lancé un défi de taille
faire le tour du québec se laver l'eau
pour aider les fans en difficulté pour
leur donner la force de croire en elle
le défi à carreaux à vélo a pour mission
aussi de ramasser des fonds pour
soutenir le chaînon est ici à montréal
mais j'ai comme objectif également de
faire rayonner toutes les maisons
d'hébergement que je vais croiser sur ma
route le défi carreau à vélo c'est un
trajet de 4400 km à travers la province
qui passera par la capitale nationale la
gaspésie et la côte-nord le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean et même la baie
james
un exploit qu'elle compte réaliser en 40
jours
mon idée première avec le défi qu'a
relevé l'osce est parlé de courage puis
d'utiliser le défi sportif en parallèle
aussi avec les défis que les femmes qui
vivent de la violence psychologique ou
physique ou autres problèmes dans la vie
on a déployé au quotidien le parcours
qui l'attend l'entousiasme mais suscite
aussi quelques appréhensions parce qu'un
tel trajet c'est une première pour elle
moi de partir comme ça tout seul aux 6
et s'embrassent à l'intérieur je peux
avoir beaucoup de peur tu es quelqu'un
d'ordinaire je suis pas une athlète pour
les femmes hébergées au chaînon qui ont
tenu à saluer caroline avant son départ
le soutien qui leur offre et chris yeh
succès important pour nous parce que si
un peu d'argent n'y a pas de maison
comme ça on se retrouve à la rue
on sait pas où aller on a besoin du
monde comme ce n'est pas facile la
situation
mais dès qu'on ville puis je trouve que
je trouve ça extraordinaire qu'est cas
facile pour nous le long périple de
caroline paradis s'est amorcée ce matin
avec ses proches qui sont déjà
impatients de la retrouver au même
endroit à la mi juin
ici et me lemieux radio canada montréal